the banner outside betrayed the police
as criminals as an inquiry found the
Mets undercover operations were
intrusive and unjustified people like
Jessica hide their identity because they
feel they were sexually abused by the
state she'd entered a relationship with
a police officer who was spying on her I
never gave consent to sleep with to have
sex with an undercover officer and how
did you feel when you found out that
this person wasn't undercover police
officer
he was 20 24 years old I found out then
that he was 32 married undercover police
officer
[Music]
this first tranche of the inquiry
examines a time when Northern Ireland
troubles threatened the mainland and
there were cold war fears of Communism
but there was also General unrest and
mostly the targets weren't serious
criminals or terrorists just activists
trade unions environmental campaigns
political parties that are perfectly
legal have been seen as a legitimate
Target in a war against their own
citizens the report identifies four
areas that should have been addressed
when this unit was set up first the
inevitable intrusion into the lives of
many hundreds of people second that any
undercover officer would be a trespasser
on people's property third they'd have
to take up positions of responsibility
in the groups they infiltrate and where
would that lead and fourth the spy's use
of deceased children's identities would
surely lead to public concern if
discovered
the unanswered question in this first
report is who knew at what level that
these things were going on the report
author certainly thinks that the likes
of Home secretaries and met
Commissioners should have been told but
there's also an inference that even if
they weren't they should have been able
to work it out we know that the future
tranches are going to show much more
recent spying on people and I'd be very
very surprised if it wasn't still going
on
so what has changed
do police officers still use deceased
babies names absolutely not do police
officers sleep with women who do not
know that they're police officers
absolutely not
um I have to see I must say that
it is absolutely abhorrent the
activities of those officers in the
sexual relationships that they had
but what about disruptive groups like
just stop oil are they today's targets
every time there is a consideration for
deploying undercover offices the regime
now for checks and balances is
completely different to what it was 40
to 50 years ago so you're not denying
that you might infiltrate a group that's
protesting against climate change
and all I'm going to say is that we
would never confirm or deny anything in
relation to undercover policing because
it would compromise it
so today's activists might be spied on
but in a more regulated way today's
report is just the beginning
it's just an interim report the full
inquiry findings are expected in three
years time Jason Farrell's Sky News